le tricheur du jour c'est qu'il y en ai
ma paix qui peine qu'on embrasse c'était
pendant reims pj hier soir en demi
finale de la coupe de la ligue et
killian il a essayé un truc j'aime bien
j'aime bien dire j'aime bien l'idée
ouais je lui dis je me donne il est
quand même assez dense cette défense du
paris saint germain
ap bape et neymar n'est mort le numéro
deux d'al hima bape et qui continue
demain
évidemment
trop fusée
deuxième carton c'est le premier pour
pape et il pense avec le sourire
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a aucune volonté de tricher juste
de plaisanter un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
le match était plié c'est d'y rester
deux minutes de jeu et le pari gagné
3,06 n'est pas grand-chose en foot mais
est-ce que c'était bien nécessaire un
carton alors qu'on voit bien qu il le
fait c'est moi on a franchement immérité
paul gasser fois également l'arrêt faut
être plus intelligent que ragogna alors
les parisiens hier soir je crois qu'ils
avaient tous oublié de jouer avec les
pieds parce que gagner 3 0 mais neymar
lui aussi il a utilisé une autre partie
de son corps regarde lui qui pourtant
des ses forces et qui connaît pas la
pression il est toujours assez
concentrés mais relâchés avant chaque
match est tenté une passe de la fait
sonner mars et mai combattants
[Musique]
avec quelque chose de laid marbre en
vous parce que vous avez fait la même
chose tu as l'air avec la balle de
ping-pong jeux vous a vu faire une
petite werc avec la balle oui mais elle
n'est pas ressorti tout ça donne eu
quelques échauffourées entre les deux
équipes parce que vince estimé qu'il se
foutait un peu de l'ordinaire mais là le
respecte et nouveaux métiers par as en
mémoire également bien sûr et moi et
rémois à ce qu'ils ont fait quand même
un beau parcours demi finale et c'est
quand même énorme